okay yes live we're live now Gabby has
take it over there real rejects I was
actually thinking of a way to rebrand
you I was thinking instead of thanks we
heat up this really hot metal piece
right yeah look I would shake a on it no
I was thinking instead of CTS at the end
it could just be ex rejects Oh Reed ex
got some file document will do because I
need to rebrand when were like a TV when
we need to be sci-fi does everyone who
is on this right now from India this is
crazy it's just keeping idea right I
keep jumping from from like channel to
channel and does everyone from India
who's like live streaming we're trying
to find out no I'm not trying to find
out anything it's just like the people
who are cool just so you guys know he's
the one who just clicked my phone and
went live it wasn't my decision right
now we're all there's some people from
the states Joseph M hey yo yo yo is that
a thing yeah Logan talking Logan be like
the movie mushroom this is this is javi
taking over the real rejects with an
exit via and no longer can explain to
anyone knew why the positioning of the
camera and all this is like this right
now javi is taking over what I'm trying
to say I'm from the Philippines what's
up hello Filipino how are you what's the
with mom what's the Filipino word for
like misty misty so oh yeah hooyah
hooyah
what's up well not older brother what
about just like bro like bro yeah great
great job on the weight lost thanks man
I appreciate that I know that's a man
because no woman watch our Channel
except for maybe three all the women
shout out right now say what all the
woman shout out what see I don't know if
a camera
more amorous right no it's funny you
guys I wish I'm an American Cano a
desire is a woman just so you guys know
John and I shop for like two hours today
we are doing a movie news segment that's
going out tomorrow transformers segment
tomorrow Monday morning Planet of the
Apes and couple reaction videos hey this
girl this girl knows me businesses JB I
spent all night watching you react to
all the episodes of permanent roommates
literally it's almost 7a here and here
in the UK you got a you got a girl from
the UK who's watching you Greg
hell yeah ladies will sweep your chimney
or weirdo will you know what I like to
do that accent when the chars right and
that's my that's my go to watch are
doing properly now yeah I know it is
follow your soul didn't see anyone with
my engineers what the chimney want to do
to me what I just did sweep your chimney
all weird all will sweep your chimney I
will I will
so y'all say no but you got to do it in
like the proper wait your chimney I will
I will I don't know I was doing an
American accent doing something you
sweep your chimney I will I will
we version sounds are you doing an
American persons impression of me the
char is not good at cockney I'm really
not
I wouldn't cook maybe ask where which
ones caught cartoons I just did it will
be a [ __ ] now oh I mess up when I'm
thinking about it all right I don't we
know thank you so I'm gonna thinking not
Christian Bale when he's caught up
between his American and Welsh accent as
well you're moving your upper lip too
much it goes that's what it is my lip is
moving too much your upper lip your
operative if I just hear someone do it
we see what most pins can no it's mostly
the terminators
think description favorited salvations
you know what Johnny Depp you know if
you just do like Johnny Depp where you
go into that deep boy saw this and it
gets a little easier okay say you say a
sentence someone savvy savvy yes well
then I'm not even reading more into the
Cure wait okay
this is up real rejects I'm a fan from
the Philippines hope you can visit here
I will one day I saw this video called
eight days in the Philippines in eight
minutes cart Fanta art Emma says I can
adapt any accent while having a person
talk around me wow it's good skill to
have he said that in an accident that's
a girl what time is a girl you were
saying no girls are watching but there
are plenty of girls watching oye you
said no girls are watching now there's
plenty of intense owl 1 2 3 Greg sounds
baa-rilliant in British law Hugh Jackman
yeah Adrian Ventura John actually good
impression is good yeah Johnson John can
do it if I'm on drawn dinner I feel
nervous or pressure it goes to my throat
and it goes to my heart and then I
started quivering their oppression of
knit how can a chart put smile face all
the time
no it's a mask like dawn and night to go
home and I take it off pull kit Sharma
Gregg is such a perfect human damaged
awesome intelligent cocky and stoned
dude sounds like a cool comic book my
[ __ ] a guy when I do this busines I
think I got his face from like Bruce
Campbell it is my second Chara is so
beautiful hey all thanks Josh holy night
you're sweet he's a head of a look
[Laughter]
around so I can be in there right
bowties Oh Dana one then here we go what
are the British words like when I've
heard like people had it once
110 three four five six seven eight rash
is wrong for get
I'm sorry farming would be a rant or
around what were you specifically what
five yeah that's right Lukas Dover yes I
got to hear the different parts of
Britain yeah man yeah Britain I gotta
hear the do not the art so I counter
like Hugh Jackson Yosemite Shankman eg
Jackman has more stuff something I don't
know what to do definitely does it I
don't know what to do
no no not a voice I'm great at it and
applause who is John Mayer New Zealand
wormwood hey someone's coming in on
weirwood right now it's a New Zealand
film that's an Australian you don't have
100 people who are watching right now
yeah oh really what's up y'all what are
y'all doing on Saturday
what are you watching a you a lot I
store a lot of sound off what are you
guys doing on a Saturday guys from JA
start naming off all the cities all
right where you guys from just right
where you're from don't say America say
like a steak if you're from America New
York City was something New York Alamo
Texas Chicago Houston Mexico Chicago New
Zealand Texas Chicago Brooke ah Serbian
when Alabama Wisconsin New Zealand Los
Angeles Angelis Mumbai Kentucky Mars now
Nepal Puerto Rico ah they're too many
Tennessee Rica Springfield John humps my
mom's belly Fresno Nepal Marilyn's
though Philippines Cybertron I feel bad
for you guys your world Manila
your world has been destroyed Sweden
definitely has just having I met a guy
from Sweden
Katmandu all right I think I think this
game stuff Greg have you watched the
room yet across the universe Ireland you
guys it's a thank you so much for take
for watching javi take over Greg's
channel real rejects with an X at the
end sup man we're going to call this
video I feel like real rejects with an X
at the end is like if we start like a
channel that's for teenagers like then
we'll do
or one that's like what we need to
rebrand I'm Jeff Iike way I roll you can
find my videos at youtube.com slash jive
equate or slash javi tube if you want to
see the American Western we're going to
make our own horn that's John Humphrey
from real rejects with an ACME or a char
Kirk from the channel with way too many
videos youtube.com slash char and Greg
from the real rejections you oh I would
love lino I take a spy chase or tie one
of you